[Applaudissements]
c'était à romeme non à Paris après
minuit juste à midi ah oui
oui je m'en souviens très
bien ce beau dimanche c'était
l'und ta robe blanche non mon manteau
gris
ah oui
oui je m'en souviens très
bien nous avons fait la
fête champagne et
caviar de malheureux
sandwich au fond d'un
B nous avons pris ma sport grand luxe ma
sport grand luxe c'était un autobus
ah oui B
oui je m'en souviens très
bien le lendemain 6 mois après main dans
la main je t'ai traîné ah oui
oui je m'en souviens très
bien de belles vacances 2 jours et demi
à la
campagne très d'ORL ah oui bah oui
écoute vraiment ah oui je m'en souviens
très
bien tous les oiseaux
chantaient sur notre
maison et moi le soir pour
m'endormir je comptais les
avions je t'ai
donné tout mon amour et la MIG
pendant 15 jours la migraine oui écoute
vraiment c'est pas possible tu me donnes
la migraine la mine mais je te jure
écoute vraiment tu es beau tu es gentil
tu plais à ces dames et tout mais alors
là oui ici là tu es un vieux machin un
vieux machin moi je suis un vieux ma tu
es un vieux écoute franchement tu te
rappelles bien la première fois mais je
peux pas oublier la première fois la
première fois tu m'as emené dans les
bois dans les bois oui parce que c'est
plus frais ou bon alors dans la première
fois tu m mis dans les bois on était
tous les deux oui
ah ça on s'en
souvient
très
[Musique]
bien